de plus en plus de ménages peinent à se
payer des services internet à la maison
pourquoi des bourses ton plus cher ici
qu'ailleurs on se penche là-dessus avec
eve lyne couturier qui est chercheuse à
l'institut de recherche et
d'informations socio économiques iris
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin
bonjour bonjour on va se comparer voulez
vous on va pas se consoler ça c'est sûr
et certain alors c'est aux états unis
que ça coûte le plus cher pour les
services mensuels internet à la maison
on parle d'en moyenne 112 dollars le
canada est deuxième avec 79 dollars mais
on se rend compte que c'est plus qu'un
d'australie s'est davantage qu'en france
au royaume-uni également aussi au japon
question pourquoi ça coûte plus cher
internet ici mais sans trop s'y
retrouvent parce que au canada on a
décidé de faire affaire avec des gros
joueurs donc plutôt que d'avoir
plusieurs petites entreprises qu'il sert
à donner internet
on a des grandes compagnies qui gère le
réseau et qui selon celui de leurs
patientes à des petits joueurs
est ce que ça fait c'est que le marché
est dominé par des grosses compagnies
qui nous chargent très cher et qui
peuvent le faire qu'ils en profitent et
nous on se retrouve un peu a écrit au
puzzle
c'est vrai qu'il ya des petites
compagnies qui offrent aussi internet
maintenance est petit qu'on fait une
offre internet sur l'instant victoire et
les gens aussi un peu moins confiant mon
c'est dans ces petits joueurs étant
donné qu'on les connaît moins donc cette
même dans une situation où on a un grand
territoire pur de plus peu de joie sur
le territoire et des coûts d'internet
qui nous coûtent très cher il y en a
nous aussi d'ailleurs des mesures pour
faire pour favoriser la concurrence fas
baisse également les tarifs mais vous
venez de le dire la statistique c'est
celle ci les gros joueurs comme rogers
bell vidéotron telus chats ont 74 % du
marché alors ça ça a un impact sur les
prix ainsi
absolument et c'est comme ça dans toutes
les provinces à chaque province se
retrouve à avoir deux gros joueurs et un
deux petits joueurs régionale et ensuite
on a les petites compagnies qui se
séparent le reste de la population née
ici peut toujours le sont principalement
dans les grands semblent donc si on se
retrouve à l'extérieur de confondre les
deux c'est encore pire quand on est dans
les régions plus rurales elles parfois
il ya actuellement aucun fournisseur qui
peut nous donner un service filaire bon
il faut avoir un service par satellite
et là ça devient extrêmement cher pour
une quantité de données qui est
relativement limitée et une vitesse qui
est pas du tout optimale et tout ça ça
fait rasseoir d'ailleurs une étude de
cas paru cette semaine tous à sa façon
que la moitié des ménages canadiens qui
touche 30 mille dollars et moins ne
peuvent se payer d'ailleurs des services
internet à la maison
alors est ce qu'internet est devenu un
bien essentiel si l'on veut absolument
essentiel qu'il faut rappeler que la
question d'internet d'accès internet si
oui en avoir la possibilité d'avoir un
abonnement mensuel pour avoir la
connexion internet
mais il faut également avoir le matériel
pour pouvoir recevoir cette connexion
internet le dos oui le téléphone est
idéalement un ordinateur une tablette
pour être en mesure de pouvoir par
exemple la recherche d'emploi de la
recherche pour cette étude rester en
contact avec les personnes de son
entourage est au courant des activités
qui se passe dans sa communauté
trouver des recettes trouver de
l'information
donc si on n'a pas la possibilité de
pouvoir s'acheter un ordinateur ou une
tablette mais on se retrouve à même si
on n'avait pas officiellement les moyens
pour se payer une connexion internet
pour pouvoir rester en contact et
internet est vraiment vu comme
nécessaire maintenant pour vivre en
société on ne peut pas vraiment faire
concevoir une personne qui par exemple
est aux études ou en recherche d'emploi
qui n'a pas accès internet cette
personne va être désavantagés par
rapport aux personnes qui ont accès à
internet et vous avez donné plusieurs
exemples un autre exemple par exemple
papa papa qui doit prendre l'autobus
pour aller à la bibliothèque pour
consulter des documents avec son enfant
alors est-ce que ça devient pas
justement un préjudice pour cet enfant
face aux autres élèves qui eux ont
internet à la maison
la lumière fait avec son verre est une
activité qui est tout à fait
extraordinaire mais en effet si cela le
seul moyen pour pouvoir avoir accès à de
l'information qui est à l'extérieur de
la bibliothèque familiale
aidé par une recherche sur les
dinosaures ça devient quelque chose de
beaucoup plus complexe demande beaucoup
plus de temps et puis là on en train on
prend l'exemple d'une famille pas assez
de moyens pour avoir un ordinateur une
connexion internet à la maison donc on
peut s'imaginer que ces personnes là on
travaille peut-être avec plus qu'un
emploi pour essayer d'arriver à pouvoir
payer la lorette de leurs dépenses pour
en plus qu'ils trouvent le temps pour
changer de trouver la bibliothèque
trouverez l'ordinateur aller sur
internet pour faire les recherches
à ce moment là c'est enfin là c'est
clair que pour ses besoins d'éducation
bien sûr trop avoir un de montage par
rapport à un enfant qu'il reste à la
maison et c'est une place et prépare en
ce moment l'autre de les soutenir et
vous aider absolument et le débord il
assez merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous paraît plaisir